y
[Música]
ucrania seguro que sus fuerzas
recuperaron localidades importantes en
jarquín en una contraofensiva para
evitar el avance de rusia entretanto
prorrusos en gerson pidieron la anexión
a putin y la defensora del pueblo de
ucrania exhortó a la onu ya la cruz roja
a ayudar en la evacuación de los
soldados heridos en azotan en la ciudad
de mar y polvo
una periodista de al yazira la palestina
share in agua que murió presuntamente
por fuego israelí durante una redada del
ejército en la ciudad de jenín al norte
de la cisjordania ocupada israel acusó
en un primer momento a palestinos
armados de ser los responsables si bien
posteriormente matizó las afirmaciones
la onu pidió investigar el asesinato
la gran barrera de coral está sufriendo
por segundo año consecutivo
blanqueamientos masivos de los corales
este fenómeno del de color a miento del
coral se produce por las temperaturas
anormalmente altas del océano un
fenómeno que alerta a los científicos en
australia
bienvenidos al nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos esta emisión en
ucrania porque en el dia 77 de la guerra
que informó que recuperó el control de
cuatro localidades importantes en heart
quitó en el noreste del país la ciudad y
sus alrededores han sido objeto de
ataques continuos desde que comenzó la
ofensiva rusa y algunos dicen que el
control de la región podría marcar un
cambio en el conflicto la bandera
ucraniana vuelve a ondear en rue abismo
o bien nuestra querida bandera es uno de
los varios pueblos retomados por el
ejército ucraniano en los últimos días
alrededor de la ciudad dejar que los
oficiales de defensa ucranianos dijeron
que las fuerzas rusas estaban siendo
empujadas fuera la ciudad y sus
alrededores han estado bajo un intenso
ataque desde el inicio de la guerra las
fuerzas armadas de nuestro estado nos
han proporcionado a todos buenas
noticias desde la región dejar que los
ocupantes están siendo gradualmente
alejados de la ciudad
pero las tropas rusas apenas ceden a la
presión están tomando territorio a unos
160 km al sureste del avance ucraniano
hacia partes del donbass que aún están
bajo control de ucrania más al sur el
vital puerto de odessa y la zona de
mykolaiv han sido objeto de intensos
bombardeos en los últimos días el martes
del director de la inteligencia nacional
de eeuu advirtió que no había un final a
la vista
la naturaleza incierta de la batalla que
se está convirtiendo en una guerra de
desgaste combinada con la realidad de
que putin se enfrenta a un desajuste
entre sus ambiciones y las actuales
capacidades militares convencionales de
rusia probablemente significa que los
próximos meses podrían vernos avanzar
por una trayectoria más impredecible
mientras las tropas ucranianas presionan
alrededor de jarquín en el noreste de
ucrania ahora podrían pasar a la
ofensiva y cortar las líneas de
suministros rusas sobre gerson ha
hablado el portavoz de vladimir putin
dmitri peskov quien aseguró que
corresponde a los ciudadanos de esa
región ucraniana decidir sobre su futuro
la afirmación llega luego que un
funcionario puesto por rusia dijera que
la región pedirá a putin que se anexione
gerson peskov afirmó que de darse dicho
escenario debe haber un fondo legal
absolutamente claro para la anexión como
el funcionario asegura ocurrió en el
caso de crimea
y sobre mariupol la defensora del pueblo
ucraniana pidió a la onu la cruz roja su
ayuda para evacuar a los soldados
heridos que resisten al cerco militar
ruso en la planta siderúrgica de a
fausta desde el interior de la acería
los militares del regimiento azor
publicaron imágenes de quienes serían
sus soldados heridos y esperan atención
médica dicen que sufrieron muchas bajas
y que los suministros escasean
estamos teniendo muchas bajas estamos
teniendo pérdidas cada día puede ser el
último tenemos recursos extremadamente
limitados y que son muy escasos por
ahora el resultado de eso podría ser
nuestra muerte inminente o ser
capturados por el enemigo lo que también
significa la muerte para nosotros
precisamente las mujeres de los soldados
que aún siguen atrincherados en la
planta de asustar se reunieron este
miércoles con el papá francisco en el
vaticano las mujeres le pidieron al sumo
pontífice de la iglesia católica que
interviniera para facilitar la
evacuación de los militares antes de que
rusia los capture o los maté le
espetaron que
su última esperanza y que los soldados
están dispuestos a deponer las armas si
son evacuados a un tercer país
y vamos hasta marruecos donde la
presencia del terrorismo yihadista en
áfrica sobre todo en la región del sahel
centra la reunión ministerial de la
coalición contra el estado islámico
organizada en marrakech nuestra
corresponsal sofía catalán no se
ampliaba sobre la reunión y sobre el
incremento de la inseguridad y de los
grupos terroristas en el sahel
marruecos arbitra este año la reunión
ministerial como dices de la coalición
internacional contra el daes que se
centra precisamente en abordar la
evolución de los grupos de terroristas
de corte yihadista en la región africana
del sahel y es que tras la derrota de
estos grupos terroristas en siria e irak
ahora estados unidos y sus aliados
buscan dicen de estabilizar el al sahel
incrementando sus intervenciones
militares y también la cooperación a
nivel financiero a la cimera a esta
cumbre personas han venido delegaciones
de los 83 estados miembros de la
coalición se han visto por aquí muchos
ministros de exteriores de países de la
unión europea y también
secretaria de estado de estados unidos
victoria nuland estaba prevista la
asistencia del propio secretario de
estado de eeuu anthony blinken pero no
pudo venir porque a ese efecto de kobe
19 y en el sahel precisamente se
registraron más del 48 por ciento del
total de muertes por terrorismo a nivel
global en el año 2021 siendo malí en
níger y burkina faso los territorios más
afectados por el avance de estos grupos
y cabe entender el avance a de la
terrorismo pues por motivos económicos
redes sociales y políticos por ejemplo
estos tres países a los que nos
referimos mali burkina faso y níger
están entre los diez más pobres del
mundo según su índice de desarrollo
humano eso a pesar de tener reservas muy
importantes por ejemplo de oro y uranio
que en realidad son explotadas por
empresas extranjeras y también los
expertos apuntan como motivos de la
inseguridad en el sahel pues a la
ausencia de los estados por ejemplo en
las zonas más rurales de estos países
también la corrupción la falta de
desarrollo de lo local y las
intervenciones y retiradas precipitadas
de ejércitos extranjeros entre otras
serán fundamentales
cambiamos de tema la cadena al yazira
acusa a israel de asesinar a sangre fría
a la periodista palestina salina bucle
de 51 años quien cubría operaciones del
ejército israelí en jenín cuando recibió
un disparo en la cara
el ejército israelí planteó inicialmente
la posibilidad de que agua que hubiera
muerto por un disparo palestino
posteriormente aseguraron que en este
momento no pueden determinar por el
fuego de quién fue la herida y lamentan
su muerte en palestina ha habido
protestas por su muerte y su cuerpo ha
sido llevado a la sede de al yazira en
ramala en la sede del canal en doha la
capital de qatar sus compañeros
periodistas le rindieron un sentido
homenaje guardando un minuto de silencio
entretanto se suceden las condenas
internacionales y la onu ha exigido la
investigación de la muerte
[Música]
el chaleco antibalas y el casco que la
identificaban como periodista no fueron
suficientes para evitar la muerte de la
palestino-estadounidense
gering abu el corresponsal del medio
qatarí al yazira un suceso que ha
conmocionado al mundo y que al yazira y
testigos atribuyen a los soldados
israelíes
es un asesinato flagrante que viola las
leyes y normas internacionales las
fuerzas de ocupación israelíes
asesinaron a sangre fría a nuestra
corresponsal en palestina el gobierno
israelí sostuvo que la muerte
posiblemente se dio por fuego palestino
pero los testigos aseguran que en ese
momento no había combatientes palestinos
al pie de toni morrison y existe una
posibilidad viable de que la periodista
haya sido alcanzada por fuego de los
palestinos armados pero para llegar a la
verdad debemos realizar una
investigación reja que los mets y
acusaron a la autoridad palestina por
rechazar una investigación conjunta
déjenme preguntar desde cuando el
criminal tiene derecho a formar parte en
la investigación de la muerte de su
víctima la muerte de agua que le ha
hecho sonar las alarmas entre la
comunidad internacional con los
sindicatos y ongs exigiendo seguridad
para los periodistas y distintos
gobiernos pidiendo una investigación
transparente
pedimos inmediatamente una investigación
rápida e independiente para que los
autores de este crimen sean llevados
ante la justicia
no es la primera vez que un periodista
palestino muere en el conflicto que esta
vez ha terminado con la vida de una
profesional con más de 20 años de
experiencia puede que no sea fácil para
mí cambiar la realidad de la situación
sobre el terreno pero al menos he podido
contribuir ayudando a que esas voces
lleguen al mundo soy zaidín a bucle y
nos vamos hasta china allí la política
cero de kobe 19 del gobierno que la
organización mundial de la salud crítica
de insostenible ha causado que cientos
de extranjeros hayan tenido que quedarse
en confinamiento estricto por meses el
gobierno chino dice que él de la oms es
irresponsable y defiende que puede
contener la variante omicron y que
debido a sus políticas ha evitado la
muerte de un millón y medio de personas
andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
65 días eso fue lo que duró confinada en
china la estadounidense laura hotz en
debido a la estricta cuarentena por la
política de 'cero kobe
recientemente he tenido como cuatro
boletos diferentes supongo para salir de
aquí para el 10 de mayo y luego algunas
rutas que van desde shanghai beijing
tratando de llegar a los ángeles así que
creo que lo conté y son como 8 o 9
boletos en total
cada dos semanas ante la posibilidad de
vivir se logra empacaba y desempacado a
maletas el 8 de marzo por la pandemia
renunció a su trabajo como profesora en
un instituto de changchun tres días
después quedó atrapada la ciudad
confirmó a sus nueve millones de
habitantes cerró el transporte público y
el aeropuerto en shanghai los vecinos de
casos positivos han sido obligados
instalaciones centrales de cuarentena
aunque hayan dado negativo para el virus
algunos funcionarios han pedido las
llaves de las casas para desinfectar los
hogares la política china de acero kobe
fue criticada por la ms por ser
insostenible
güi güi güi jaf disco estos botes suisse
hemos discutido este tema con expertos
chinos y les hemos indicado que la
aproximación no será sostenible y
considerando el comportamiento del virus
creo que un cambio sería muy importante
el gobierno de decir jinping reaccionó
en los comentarios o encima dijo wells
esperamos que los interesados analicen
la política de prevención y control de
la pandemia de china de forma objetiva y
racional y sean más conscientes de los
hechos en lugar de hacer comentarios
irresponsables
millones de personas permanecen aisladas
en sus viviendas hay jornadas de
detección masivas en las principales
ciudades y cientos de extranjeros como
el ahora intentan salir de las ciudades
confinadas y siguen a la espera de poder
volver a sus lugares de origen
y en australia los expertos climáticos
están alarmados la autoridad del parque
marino de la gran barrera de coral que
depende del gobierno australiano publicó
su informe anual en el cual la alerta
del blanqueamiento de buena parte del
coral a causa del aumento de las
temperaturas en el océano un fenómeno
que no es nuevo pero que ahora no otorga
espacio suficiente entre diferentes
episodios para que el coral se recupere
y gabriel coll sen tiene los detalles
un informe alarmante es el cuarto evento
de blanqueamiento masivo de la barrera
de coral en siete años y el segundo en
dos años consecutivos
719 arrecifes fueron inspeccionados
desde el aire en marzo y el 91 por
ciento mostró decoloración por ser grave
bueno estamos en el arrecife stanley que
es un hermoso arrecife pero hay mucha
decoloración aquí mucho blanqueamiento
de las aguas poco profundas muchas
especies diferentes blanqueando sé así
que no solo los corales ramificados sino
también un montón de corales masivos
blanqueando se en las aguas poco
profundas y enlosado ahora la
decoloración es causada por una
exposición prolongada al calor y
australia vivió fenómenos
particularmente fuertes entre diciembre
de 2021 y abril de este año que
trastocaron el ecosistema de más de
2.300 kilómetros pero es la primera vez
que el blanqueamiento ocurre bajo
condiciones del fenómeno de la niña que
normalmente se caracteriza por
temperaturas más frías en el pacífico
meses esto nos rompe el corazón es muy
preocupante y muestra que nuestra
barrera de coral está realmente
problemas
hemos asistido a un blanqueamiento muy
extendido durante un año de la niña en
el que normalmente el arrecife tendría
un poco de respiro ha afectado a las
tres principales regiones del arrecife
sherif según informa la agencia estatal
el coral blanqueado está estresado pero
sigue vivo por lo cual podría sobrevivir
al evento la crisis climática es la
mayor amenaza para la que es considerada
la especie de vida más grande de la
tierra de ella dependen miles de
especies marinas en un delicado y cada
vez más amenazado balance marítimo que
además es una rica fuente de recursos de
explotación humana
hasta aquí este repaso a las principales
noticias internacionales sigan
conectados a france 24 y les recordamos
que pueden ampliar toda esta hay mucha
más información en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
[Música]